good evening and welcome to a special
edition of tucker carlson tonight we're
coming to you from budapest
earlier this week we traveled to the
southern tip of hungary along the
serbian border
it was at that spot six years ago that
hundreds of thousands of migrants in
north africa and the middle east
showed up all hoping to reach the
famously generous welfare states of
western europe
and yet by the time we arrived at that
same border on wednesday all was quiet
and peaceful there was no suffering mass
of humanity
no crying children no graffiti or trash
or violence
in fact there was just a simple
chain-link fence separating the two
countries and nobody in sight just birds
and trees
so how did this happen it happened
because hungary is a
serious and modern country that cares
about its own citizens
hungary has no desire to destroy itself
no desire to encourage
crime and misery and unemployment in its
cities
or for that matter no desire to
contribute to the human trafficking of
people fleeing from syria
when illegal aliens arrive at the
hungarian border now they are
photographed and then they're politely
escorted back
across the line the whole process takes
about half an hour
it is the most civilized thing we have
seen in years
and as we watched it we thought to
ourselves why can't we have this
in america the answer is you know is
because our leaders don't want to have
it
they benefit from the chaos and the pain
of illegal immigration
when the rule of law collapses they
become more powerful
that's why we have open borders fox's
bill malugin has spent months
covering the man-made tragedy unfolding
in our southern border he joins us
tonight
with an update hey bill
hey tucker good evening to you so look
local officials here in hidalgo county
are just not pleased with the federal
government they say the biden
administration is just not doing its job
when it comes to enforcing immigration
down here at the border so they say
they got to fill that void and do it for
them so we'll show you what they've had
to do here take a live look
at our fox drone right now the city of
mcallen has had to build an emergency
tent compound in the middle of a park
here in mission texas
with the specific purpose of housing
covid 19 positive illegal immigrants
who have been released from federal
custody they say they have to do this
because the federal government has
essentially
been dumping migrants in downtown
mcallen they can't handle the capacity
anymore neither can the local catholic
charity
many of them are testing positive they
got to build this to keep them in one
place because of the health risk take a
look at this video
we shot on the ground earlier today we
were given one hour of access to go in
there and take a look at it
the current capacity started at 250 but
they say they're expanding it all the
way up to
650 migrants not everybody in there is
coveted positive some of them are family
members
who decided to quarantine with their
loved ones but you can see there are
hundreds of people in there and again
the city
furious they put out a scathing
statement towards the feds which reads
in part quote
the city intends to demand relief from
the federal government
for the alarming number of immigrants
that are being released into the city of
mcallen and quote
as these immigrants are released the
federal government does not test them
for covid19 the testing question they're
tested
by a third party once they're dropped
off in mcallen and look at this shocking
graphic
right here the city of mcallen says just
since the month of february the federal
government
has released more than seven thousand
coveted 19 positive migrants into their
city
including 1500 of which were just in the
last week alone and tucker back out here
live what happens with the covet
positive folks in this compound is
once they test negative they're free to
go their sponsors will show up their
family members will show up we've seen
it happening
they can come pick them up and then they
just take them elsewhere into the united
states
wherever they want to go so far we've
talked to people who are picking them up
and taking them to houston and louisiana
we'll send it back to you
militia on the border thanks so much
unlike you
being forced to wear masks and get the
vaccine they have total freedom those
foreign nationals breaking our laws
what's interesting is you don't
typically see waves like this of human
migration
in mid-summer historically june and july
have been
light months for border crossings for
mexico it's just too hot
but this year is different the world's
poor understand that america no longer
has
borders joe biden invited millions to
come and then promise them
free health care and education and
housing when they arrived
so they're coming you would too why
wouldn't they
the migrants arriving are coming in
unprecedented numbers from around the
world many thousands from brazil
alone but they're also coming from
africa asia the caribbean the middle
east all over latin america
our country has literally never seen
anything
like this the question is what does it
do for americans how does it approve
your life or the life of any citizen
here and by the way
why should you obey our laws now that
the white house has told the rest of the
world it doesn't have to
no one in authority has explained any of
that at the same time the downsides of
all this are becoming very
obvious to everybody try as they do to
squelch it
a few days ago for example in minnesota
an illegal alien from cuba
beheaded a woman in broad daylight as
she was sitting in traffic
bystanders found her head in an
intersection by her car
it was an awful crime obviously but the
worst part was it didn't need to happen
authorities had been aware for years
that the killer was living illegally in
this country
but they refused to deport him because
he had rights
even now most in the news media will not
report the fact that he was an illegal
alien
telling you that might discredit joe
biden's immigration policy
huh again this is not natural it is a
manufactured
disaster it's not a tornado it's not an
act of god
the biden administration did this on
purpose and they're still
doing it and that is exactly why
democrats become
hysterical when you mention the obvious
successes that are on display here in
hungary
on the immigration question they don't
want you to know that there is an option
to the chaos and filth and crime
growing all around us we don't have to
live like that
anymore actually we could have a
functioning country
all we'd have to do is to uphold our own
laws the ones already on the books
but that's not happening instead the
administration is using american courts
to encourage more illegal immigration
from other countries
in his immigration plan joe biden
proposes millions more in federal
dollars to lawyers
in order to defend foreign nationals
caught entering our country
so as an american citizen you can be
summarily fired from your job for not
taking the unapproved covet vaccine
yet if you sneak into our country
violating our laws and your covet
positive coming from
haiti or brazil or ghana or honduras
you get a free lawyer you get free
housing and then you get free health
care
so watching all this after a while you
begin to wonder
what's the point of having american
citizenship what's the point of paying
your taxes
other smaller countries far less
privileged places
have figured this out here's footage
that we just shot in budapest
notice as you watch it which you don't
see there are not
ten cities of drug addicts living in the
parks here
there isn't garbage and human waste
littering the sidewalks people don't get
beheaded at intersections
blm is not allowed to torch entire
neighborhoods
in budapest that's how americans used to
live
before leaders decided they no longer
cared about you
the hungarian government protects its
border because it wants to protect
its citizens that's the basic role of
government it's not a radical concept
it used to be commonplace across the
world especially
in the united states and now it's not
here's the prime minister of hungary
explaining it victor orban
this is our country this is our
population this is our history
this is our language so we have to do
that of course if you are in trouble
and there is nobody closer to you than
the hungarians you have to be helpful
but you can't say simply that okay it's
a nice country i would like to come here
and to live here because it's a nicer
life
this is not a human right to come here
no way because it's our land
it's a nation it's a community families
history
tradition language
oh they're so triggered by that family
history tradition
language quote they hate it when you say
that but why
those are all good things in fact
they're the things that unite
a country particularly a huge
continental country
that's multi-ethnic you need those
things
it's not hard to have a decent country
it's not complicated
you just need leaders who want one hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else